EU leaders failed to agree their
position on the bloc's next 7-year
budget at their last summit Parliament's
will discuss the deadlock with council
president Jean Michel while continuing
to defend its priorities like the fight
against climate change and sufficient
funding for successful programmes the
European Commission will outline its
proposal for the e use first climate law
the text a cornerstone of Europe's Green
Deal sets out how the EU will achieve a
carbon neutral economy by 2050 more than
a hundred million Europeans live with a
disability Parliament's will discuss how
the EU can ensure accessibility equal
employment opportunities and freedom of
movement for all people with
disabilities kovat 19 is continuing to
spread em EPS will examine the
coordinated measures the EU is taking
and how best to support countries
affected by the outbreak since Turkey
opened its border last week thousands of
refugees have tried to cross into Greece
the EU has pledged both financial
support and Frontex officers to help the
country cope MEP s will discuss the EU
response